I saw your new film uncut gems about
four days ago left me the best text it
is without reservation the best film
that I have seen in quite a long time
it's an amazing movie your performance
is crazy it's crazy and you're getting a
lot of the attention for this
performance that you truly deserve and I
hope you can enjoy it you have to see
this movie this movie is absolutely
incredible
there really thank you so much and I
told me you think it means just the guy
that provides ham but in the movie you
deliver him I can do about that but you
know this I mean uncut gems it's this
it's this amazing performance and
they're in and I thought about the movie
the next day I thought after that
everyone else has seen the movie we all
need to talk about it it's one of those
movies that stays with you well the guys
who wrote the safty brothers and and and
Ronnie Bronstein these they're just
they're just young guys who are so
enthusiastic and want to do great work
and they hope they put me in it and but
when I wasn't when I told them that you
like that they would not say like Conan
O'Brien because they yeah they're like
these guys here like they're these two
especially just like that it was those
guys that's not the other safty Brothers
right yeah yeah yeah but but they just
was so happy and it's so cool because
they talked to me about my old albums
and stuff in there like a young a young
guys who kind of grew up loving you and
and they tolerated me and there and it's
just cool it's cool it's cool to being
on the other end having a youth this
character you nail this character so
thoroughly they must did they write this
for you because it's a it's it's great
it's not you it's a different person but
you inhabit this person so completely
it's riveting
it's
is riveting they wrote it for me they
like 10 years ago and I was and I and I
didn't you know they sent it to me sandy
got a hold of it my manager yeah he said
absolutely not guardians of the galaxy
[Laughter]
so he put a pass on that and then I
guess a couple other people they talked
to and that didn't happen then if like
five years later they offered to me
again I didn't see it and old sandy
stepped in and goes white sheesh I read
this pshh I guess they did it again ten
years later and yeah and then I got a
hold of it and I saw they were other
movies Society brothers yeah great great
time and daddy longlegs and all those
great movies they did and I got excited
to do it wouldn't well there's so many
great scenes there's a scene where and I
don't want to give any spoilers for this
but there's a scene where your character
gets in a real Jam and is ends up naked
in the trunk of his own car yes and he's
a gambler so he's got he's got yeah he's
got problems and they ended up in the
tree yeah he gets in he's gets in
trouble with some tough people and he
ends up making the trunk of his own car
and is that the kind of scene where
you're you're wearing like some flesh
colored kind of thing where you're
protected I don't know why I didn't they
offered it to me they offer but I did
I'd rather it's those are so tight and
so gross the tight stuff on me like a
speedo or something makes makes it looks
even even grosser yeah so I was like
let's just no one's gonna be watching
then I was nude in the GC were really
nude in the trunk I'm nude in the trunk
and which is good we shoot a bunch of
takes I'm nude in there and I'm in a
trunk alone so the no one's seeing this
the camera's not on the they gets close
but they don't show that anything in
anyways that's good we get the shot they
were going to lunch that's we got it
let's you know an hour lunch and
everyone's leaving
and
oh [ __ ] I got a oh no I gotta get out of
the trunk
you know and then there's all the crew
guys hanging out still no one's rushing
to lunch and I'm like good lord will you
please go to lunch so I can get out of
here yeah I like that what the hell I I
I gotta get to get out and they gonna
see me naked and then I have that
discussion like do I shoot on the front
or the back sweatshirt in the trunk
sighs like I can hide something both are
pretty unpleasant to see I went would
cover in the front cover the front shirt
on the back and apparently they canceled
lunch now are you this movie it's it's
you know it is a very mature film it has
some very funny moments in it but it is
not a comedy it lacks in that sense your
kid's gonna see this movie well Idina
Menzel's in it yeah and they keep plays
your wife she's my wife in it and she's
you know a great lady and a great
actress and a great singer but she's in
frozen so my kids wanted to come by the
set a lot and see her and I kept saying
that isn't a good movie for you to come
by and blah blah blah
she was very nice to them she called
them and and like would they would sing
on the phone and stuff that kind of
she's awesome but my kids I think part
of my biggest fear was my kids seeing
this movie someday and my wife was you
know I want my wife school she can
handle the this psychotic guy that I
played but my my kids I don't want to
see that and they were like born can we
see it
and when we're 15 and I said nah maybe
after 15 and they're like 19 I said I
don't know maybe if you when you're 50
you know it's like it's weird it's gonna
be weird for them to see what there's a
part in the I mean you've you've turned
in a lot of great dramatic acting turns
and and shown your acting chops for a
long time you've done it many times but
in this movie there's a scene where you
really break down and
is extremely powerful and it's a
terrific scene and I just remember
thinking like how do you do that like
how do you cry like that
as an actor I wouldn't be able to do
that you can't write because I don't
know why the how I what happens is I'm
not good at crying in real life I don't
cry that much do you guys cry yeah quick
quick to cry Andy no not quick to cry
but I cry very sensitive guy Adam I know
you are you're a great guy but I didn't
know you were a crybaby no but when I
was a kid I used to cry all the time I
loved it I loved looking in the mirror
when I cried I'd beaten up I would go
down the hall when I was crying and
crying over my room and then the
bathroom and stare in the mirror but um
as I got older I don't cry my wife cries
she looks up at me to cry with her I'm
just like I don't know how to cry I'm
not great a car I'm nice to my wife
crying I'm like yeah I hope you feel
better if she's like do you ever cry I'm
like I don't know how to do that anymore
yeah but yeah so when I did the movie
whenever it says in the indus script
that said here's a terrible cry and I
went oh no man I let me block that out
and when it comes to the day I'll just
cry right we'll figure that out so it's
the day I'm like you know all right
we'll see what happens the director
Benny comes on Benny safety did you guys
see good time anybody see good time I
thought he he's in that movie he plays
one of the brothers he cries in that
movie it's unbelievable he's just he's
just great so he says are you ready for
the scene I say yeah yeah yeah yeah well
let's see what happens he goes yeah yeah
and you ready to cry and I go well you
know we'll try to get there if it
doesn't we'll see what happens at Bowie
he goes well it's got to happen and I go
you know but we'll see you know we just
got to see what you know we got a plate
plate a moment he's like what do you
mean a moment you gotta cry the terrible
cry and then he goes he goes here's what
I do if I want to cry I think about
something and and I swear to God
like three seconds I see him then he's
bald and crying on my trailer I'm just
going home man he's good at crying yeah
yeah and and he something something when
he can connect real quick to something
that upsets him so anyways he leaves and
I'm like oh Sh I got a really Christ I I
called my wife up and I said we got it
I got a cry man like in this next scene
and like there I got five minutes to get
out there and you got to tell me what I
should you know help me out here she
gave me some stuff to think about and
then I and I said yeah that's good and I
went in there and I was crying I'm
pretty good and and the actress Julia
Fox who was a sort of your your
girlfriend right right yeah my
characters having an affair and with
stuck my girlfriend right and and it's
her first movie she's excellent in the
movie but but she hasn't done a lot of
movie so she I'm crying immediately I'm
looking up ready to start to see and I
Julia said something like are we rolling
and I was like this these tears only can
last so I'm just curious what your wife
told you to think about that would made
you cry Conan has no ham this year
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we have a clip here from uncut gems and
I think this is a scene where there's so
much desperation in this movie and and
your character has a gambling issue and
I believe this is a scene where you're
trying to see if you can pawn something
get some money I want to see I wanna see
I'm not sure what it is I'm sorry that's
it okay put no work into this all right
let's take a look at this clip uncut gem
yeah you take lightning bet yeah but you
don't want any portal lightning come on
come on $1,000 a point okay take this
and this is a different what's this foot
just graduating me for all this time
okay I already have I don't need you
watch listen probably fellow if we [ __ ]
anyway listen what do you know going at
this going at down what do you know I
don't know I just know well I'll tell
you what I know it's the dumbest looking
bet I ever heard of I disagree I
disagree
uncut gems uncut gems is in theaters
everywhere Christmas Day do yourself a
favor and and go and see this film it
will blow you away I am so happy for you
out of you and for the absolutely
incredible absolutely incredible Adam